[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIM DESMOND: Welcome, everyone.
I'm Van Riper.
I run the gPause, our
mindfulness programs,
community programs for
employees here at Google.
And I'm really proud and
happy to have Tim Desmond here
with us today.
I actually don't know
Tim all that well myself,
but it's one of the great things
about our community programs
is it's not just me.
There's a group of like
200 or more Googlers
that are very passionate
about mindfulness, well-being,
self-compassion.
And one of those Google
are is actually reached out
to me saying they really would
recommend that we bring Tim in,
and then I got to check out
his stuff, and it was awesome.
And I really liked that his
work is around developing
your skills, because just like
in the work of people like
Richie Davidson, they're
learning that well-being--
they are skills
that we can develop.
And I'm looking
forward to hearing
from Tim about
how we can develop
our self-compassion skills.
So with that, I'm going to turn
over the-- oh, one last thing,
just for those people
on the live stream.
Thank you, Brandy.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MICHAEL VAN RIPER: So
we have a Dory link,
which I didn't give
Tim in advance,
but it's go slash, Tim's
name, Tim Desmond, dash dory.
So for those you're
on the live stream
and you want to have us
answer a question at the end,
please take advantage of
that go link and do that.
Thank you, Brandy.
So with that, no further ado,
I will turn it over to Tim.
Welcome, Tim.
TIM DESMOND: Good
morning, everybody.
So on November 14,
2016, just a couple
of days after Donald
Trump won the election,
my wife woke up in the middle of
the night in excruciating pain.
A trip to the ER revealed
that the cancer that she she'd
been fighting for
more than a year
had spread into her abdomen,
and there was a tumor
that was blocking her kidney.
A few hours later, she
came out of surgery,
and she had a plastic tube
implanted into her side that
drained urine into a bag.
And we were told that she
was going to probably have
that for the rest of her life.
She still has it.
And when our 3-year-old son
came into the hospital room,
I had to teach him
not to touch her tube.
So that was a moment that I
could just kind of hear despair
calling me, almost audibly.
Like it was basically just
saying your life is shit.
Everything is fucked
up, and your best option
is just to go cower
in the corner or run.
But looking at my wife and
son, it was just so clear
that they needed me.
And they didn't need me to
do anything in particular,
they needed me to be able
to be there for them.
To be present, to help them
feel that they're not alone
and that life is still worth
living, that that beauty
and joy are still possible.
But how is that?
How can that happen in a
moment in which everything
seems like it's going wrong?
That's what I want
to talk about today.
There is a capacity
that we can develop
that allows us to stay human,
to be able to stay present,
to be able to care and stay
connected in whatever situation
we find ourselves in.
My teacher-- I've been a student
of a Buddhist monk and peace
activist, Thich Nhat Hanh, for
about 20 years, and my teacher,
Thich Nhat Hanh, the word
that he uses for this capacity
is mindfulness.
But at this point, I'm not sure
how I feel about that word,
because it's a word
that's used so often,
and used to mean a lot
of different things
to a lot of different people.
For some people, mindfulness
just means taking a deep breath
or sitting on a
cushion on the floor,
or just sort of paying attention
to your thoughts and feelings
with disinterest, like you're
watching a boring TV show.
But for my teacher,
for Thich Nhat Hanh,
mindfulness is talking
about this exact capacity.
It's talking about a
way of relating to life,
a way of relating especially
to suffering with compassion
and joy and
equanimity and wisdom,
a way of relating
to life that allows
us to be more fully alive.
In the book that I'm
talking about here,
I call that capacity
self-compassion,
to kind of highlight
the element of caring,
the element of compassion
in it, but it doesn't
matter what you call it.
What matters is
that we recognize
how incredibly precious it
is, that we really understand
why we're here, that
we really understand
what feels important to you.
And for me, it's this capacity
to stay human, this capacity
to stay connected.
Whether it's experiencing
tragedy in your own life,
whether it's experiencing
challenges at work,
whether it's successes
or failures or just
kind of the monotony
of day-to-day life.
That we can develop
this capacity
to be more fully alive, and
to be more fully connected.
And this is a
capacity that we can
develop that I think of as sort
of made out of some component
skills.
We're going to talk about
just a handful of them here,
and in my workbook, we
go through a lot more.
And the first skill that
I want to talk about,
that helps us to
develop this capacity,
is the skill of recognizing
what's beautiful in life.
A lot of us spend
a lot of our time
just paying attention to what
isn't OK in life, everything
that we want to change, all the
problems we're trying to solve.
So I want to talk about
this skill of being
able to remember, to not
forget, to not ignore everything
that's beautiful in life.
In every moment of life, there
are infinite reasons to suffer,
and in every moment of life
there are infinite reasons
to be happy.
And what matters is where
we're bringing our attention,
what we're paying attention to.
If we were just to take
a few minutes right now,
make a list of everything
that you could be upset about,
I don't think
anybody would run out
of things to put on that list.
But if we were to take
the same amount of time
and make a list of
everything that you could
be happy about, whether it's
like the colors of a sunset
or the experience of
health in your body.
We'd never run out of
those items either.
So there is a skill that
is about training ourselves
to notice, to be
able to pay attention
to what's beautiful in life.
Now, if we focus
all of our attention
on everything-- so most
of us go through life
believing that the only way
it's possible to be happy
is when all of our conditions
for suffering are gone.
Right?
I can be happy when
I fix this problem
and when I've
achieved that goal.
And then at that
point, once there's
no more reasons
for me to suffer,
then that's when
happiness is possible.
But we also know that that's
never going to happen.
There will never
be a moment in life
that you won't be able to
find a reason to suffer,
if you're looking for it.
And that's why it's
so important for us
to develop the skill to
learn how to notice what's
already good, notice
what's already
beautiful in our lives that's
available right in this moment.
And as we begin to
do that, we also
begin to recognize
everything that isn't wrong.
Like, right now, if you had a
tooth ache, if you had pain,
like a dental pain,
you'd be thinking,
if only I didn't have a
tooth ache, I'd be so happy.
And you don't have a
tooth ache right now,
and so then the question
is, is it possible
for you to enjoy your
non-toothache right
in this moment?
Is it possible to
train myself to be
able to notice those things?
And it's not naive to
look at life this way.
I mean, if anything,
it's pretty irrational
to be so focused on the
never-ending stream of problems
in life to the point that
we become debilitated by it.
We can think of experiences
of beauty and joy
as kind of like the fuel
that we need in order
to be able to be present when
something doesn't go well.
And if we don't fill up
that reservoir in ourselves,
we won't have the energy to
be able to deal with life
when we're exposed to
some real difficulty.
So coming back to my
story, coming back
to that hospital room.
So there I am, with
my wife and son,
in a moment when it feels like
everything is going wrong.
And more than anything,
what I want in that moment
is to be able to be
a resource for them,
to be able to be there
for them in a way that's
going to be helpful.
How can I do it?
So in that moment, I stop.
I pause.
I let go of whatever I'm
trying to do in that moment.
I let go of any desires,
including the desire
to feel any different or
be any different than I am.
And I come back just
to the sensations
in my body in that moment.
And when I do, it
is not pleasant.
What I find is an intense
amount of tension,
agitation, an intense amount
of just kind of heaviness.
And I give myself
permission just
to feel it, just to allow it
to be there, just bringing kind
of an open acceptance
to exactly what I'm
feeling in this moment.
And as I let go of
struggling against what's
real for me, what
I'm actually feeling,
as I bring sort of
acceptance and compassion
to myself in that
moment, it's like I
come into the present in
a really different way.
And I recognize
this voice in me,
this voice that's
just saying, no.
This is not OK.
I don't accept this.
I don't accept that
this is happening,
and I pause, and I listen
to myself with compassion.
I don't fight against myself.
I don't start arguing against
myself, but I just listen.
And I recognize that
that voice is suffering
so much is that what is so
difficult in that moment what
that voice is saying is I
don't want to lose my wife,
that I'm really
scared of losing her.
But as I come into the
present a little more,
I recognize that
she's here with me.
She's alive in this moment.
That all of this
suffering that's
coming up for me, all in this
distress that's coming up
for me, is about the
fear of losing something
that I haven't lost yet.
And I recognize, and I see this
is a moment that she's alive.
This is a moment in which I'm
here, with my wife and my son,
and it's not a moment to grieve.
It's a moment to celebrate.
When I give talks
about mindfulness,
there's a story that
I'll sometimes tell.
It's about sort of
listening to ourselves,
listening to sort of
what's underneath whatever
our behaviors are, and
the story goes like this.
Imagine somebody is driving on
a highway, and they get cut off,
and they just go into a rage.
And they roll down the
window, and they're
screaming obscenities, and maybe
like they throw a plastic water
bottle at the other car.
If you could pause in that
moment and ask that person,
why are you doing that?
They might say, because
this jerk cut me off.
But if we look a
little deeper, we
might ask, OK, so why is
that so upsetting to you?
Well, because it was really
unsafe and disrespectful.
OK, so the need that's up
for you right in this moment
is safety and respect.
You'd like to feel more
safety and more respect.
Right?
Yeah, obviously, and
so what you're doing,
to seek greater
safety and respect,
is chasing somebody
down the highway,
sticking your head out the
window and screaming at them.
In that moment, I
felt as misguided
as the person in
my story, just sort
of lost in grief about
something that hadn't happened.
And actually, in a moment
that I can celebrate.
That's what I mean
by the practice
of recognizing what's already
beautiful and being fed by it.
The second skill that I
want to talk about today--
I sort of alluded
to in that story--
is the skill of--
the skill of being
able to come home
to your body with
acceptance and compassion.
Whatever is taking
us away, whatever
is getting in the way of our
ability to be fully present,
our ability to be fully human
in any situation, at least
the most basic level, we
can think of as distress.
Right?
And that on one of
the most basic levels,
we can think of distress as
a physiological response that
happens in the body.
In fact, from the perspective
of Buddhist psychology,
any emotion is made out of
this physiological component
and a tendency to
think in a certain way.
So for example,
anger is considered
to be made up of a
physiological reaction
combined with a tendency
to think angry thoughts.
So this is a practice
of coming home
to that physiological
response in the body
and bringing acceptance
and compassion.
So at probably the
most basic level,
just being able to accept my
own physiological response
to a situation,
we might consider
the absolute floor
of self-compassion
of self-acceptance.
It is OK for my body to be
doing what it's doing right now,
as opposed to it's not OK
for whatever my body is--
whatever's happening
in my body right now.
So we can consider
that in some ways
just the most basic
level of self-acceptance
or self-compassion.
But bringing compassion to
the sensations in our body
has another element.
I'm going to flip through
a couple of slides here.
So first, this is Annie.
This is my wife after one
of our many hospital visits.
And then this is
the person that I
want to talk about
now, Jaak Panksepp.
Panksepp is probably
one of-- or was--
one of the most
well-known affective
neuroscientists in the world,
actually coined the term
affective neuroscience.
He's a neuroscientist who
focuses on the study of emotion
in the brain.
This is a photo of him with
some of his best friends,
his lab rats.
So Panksepp, in the
course of his research,
he discovered what he calls
basic emotional circuits
in the brain.
He was really
particularly interested
in coming to understand
well-defined anatomical
structures in the brain that
all mammals share, that give
rise to what he would
call basic emotions.
And one of the seven
basic emotional circuits
that Panksepp discovered
he calls the care circuit.
It's basically the brain
circuit that all mammals
share that regulates
caretaking behaviors.
If you're feeling
warmth and love,
if it were possible to image
your brain with enough detail,
we would see that the
care circuit in your brain
is active.
That it's releasing
oxytocin and natural opiates
to give you that
warm fuzzy feeling.
Panksepp discovered that the
care circuit in your brain
is one of the
primary tools that we
have for emotional regulation.
That for any man
experiencing distress,
if you can activate the
care circuit in your brain,
he'll say you can do
so either naturally
or using micro electrodes
in animal studies.
Just turning on the care
circuit in your brain,
that your experience of
distress drops dramatically.
And so one thing
that we're learning
how to do in this practice
is we can consider compassion
training at some level utilizing
the care circuit in your brain
to regulate distress.
Getting in touch with a
feeling of warmth and love,
and allowing that to regulate
distressing emotions.
And I'm going to
tell a little story
about utilizing this
practice or process in kind
of a high pressure environment.
I think it was October
13th or so, 2011.
Mayor Bloomberg in New York
City gave an eviction notice
for all of the protesters at
Occupy Wall in Zuccotti Park.
What he said was
that the protesters
needed to evacuate the park, so
the park can be power washed.
Most of the
demonstrators assumed
that this was just kind
of a way of clearing out
the demonstrations.
And in fact, Saturday Night
Live made a joke about anyone
who spent much time
in New York City
doesn't see a lot of
evidence of public parks
being power washed.
So that night
Hundreds of protesters
rented industrial cleaning
equipment and cleaned the park,
and a call went out to
resist the eviction.
And so the next morning, before
dawn, more people than ever
were crowded into
Zuccotti Park, shoulder
to shoulder for the
entire public park.
And I was asked with
another organizer,
Nicole [? Cardy, ?] to
facilitate the General
Assembly the next morning.
So I remember standing
up on a low stone wall
and looking out into
this sea of humanity.
We were entirely penned
in by police in riot gear.
There were helicopters
overhead, and
this enormous military-level
police presence,
and Nicole and I were
tasked with doing
something impossible.
We're supposed to facilitate
a consensus meeting
with tens of thousands of people
in imminent physical danger.
And I remember looking out
into this group of people
and seeing the terror that
was in so many of their faces,
that threatened to
overcome our hope
and turn this
gathering into chaos.
And in that moment,
all that I wanted to do
was to be a resource
to ground the energy.
I wanted to be--
I wanted to project calm
and serenity and connection,
but I was just as freaked
out as anybody else.
Possibly more so, because I'm
supposed to be facilitating
this, co-facilitating it.
So in that moment, I
remember looking out
into this crowd of people,
and again, just stopping
and coming back to my body.
And again becoming
aware of just the
shakiness the
agitation the pressure,
just as physical
sensation in my body.
And in that moment,
what I said to
myself was, whatever you
feel right now is OK.
It can be as strong
as it wants to be.
I sort of spoke to the fear in
me, and said, it's OK for you
to be here.
You can be as strong as you
want to be, and as I did,
the sensation got a lot worse.
But I didn't worry, because
I've had enough experience
with this practice that I
know that happens sometimes.
So I told myself--
so I kind of spoke to
the fear in me saying,
you can be as strong as
you want to be, and it did,
got really intense.
And I basically just
said, you can be as afraid
as you want to be.
This fear can be as
strong as you want to be,
and you're still loved.
You're still OK.
I can be here for you.
That moment is what we
might call equanimity
with compassion.
For a lot of us, when
we think of compassion,
we think of compassion
without equanimity.
The idea that I care so much
about your well-being that
to see you suffering kills me.
And that it's hard for me to
be around, or it's hard for me
to help.
It sort of burns me out
to care of this much.
You can consider that
compassion without equanimity.
And then on the other
hand, sometimes we
can have equanimity
without compassion.
What that might consider
equanimity without compassion
is kind of like, oh yeah, things
like this happen every day.
You read the news,
and you're like,
yeah, things like that happen
every day, not surprised,
and you're not move at
all to want to help.
It doesn't really stir you.
We consider that sort of
equanimity without compassion.
But the image for what I
want to talk about here,
that I feel like is maybe
the most important component
of developing our
capacity to stay human,
is equanimity with compassion.
And the archetype of
equanimity with compassion
is the way that we
hold a crying baby.
My teacher Thich
Nhat Hanh, when he
talks about mindfulness
practice, he says,
what you're learning how to do
is to be present with yourself
and especially present
with your suffering.
In the way that you would hold
a crying baby, with that kind
of openness and warmth and care.
And he's not talking
about the way
that we might actually hold
a crying baby, when it's
3:00 O'clock in the morning, and
you're just totally burned out.
What he means is
that there is a way
to hold a crying baby that
that baby experiences as deeply
comforting.
And it's not you're
holding the baby,
and you're just like,
God, will you shut up.
OK, I'm holding you, see,
holding you, now stop.
It's a way that I think
that we can all relate to,
that you're holding this
baby with the attitude of,
it's OK if you cry, and
it's OK if you stop.
Whatever you're feeling
is fine with me,
and I'm here for you,
whatever you need.
It's not the kind
of equanimity--
so sometimes we
get confused when
we think about our
adult relationships,
because we feel like to
have compassion for somebody
means that we don't really
accept their suffering.
We have to fix them.
Or we might feel like
having equanimity
is like, well, you're going
through something hard,
so I'm just going to--
so that's fine with
me, that you're
going through something hard.
But there is a compassion with
equanimity in which I can be--
whatever you're going
through doesn't bother me,
like I recognize
that's part of life.
And yet, I'm here for you, if
there's anything that I can do,
I will.
And so in this
meeting, I'm trying
to relate to my own
suffering in this way.
I'm feeling this fear as
borderline terror in me,
and saying, you can be as
afraid as you want to be.
I'm here for you,
whatever you need.
And as I do, it gets
worse for a few minutes.
Maybe not even a minute,
and then it starts to relax,
and I start to get this sense
of whatever feeling comes up
is OK.
It doesn't threaten
my value as a person,
that love and compassion are
available whatever is coming up
with me, regardless.
And there's
something that's just
profoundly comforting
for a human being
to have that experience,
and that's really
what we're training
ourselves to be
able to do in the practice
of self-compassion.
And as I started to settle,
I looked out in this crowd,
and it was just so obvious to me
that there is nowhere on earth
that I'd rather be.
I'm surrounded with
tens of thousands
of people who are
risking their comfort
and their safety to try to
make the world a little better,
in whatever way that they think
might make the world better.
But that they're
putting their bodies
on the line for something
that they believe in,
and seeing that insight,
I just fell in love
with everybody, every
single person in that crowd.
And I think that they could
feel it, and the energy relaxed.
And about 20 minutes into
that general assembly,
we got word that Bloomberg
and Brookfield Properties,
that manages the park, had
rescinded their evacuation
notice.
And so there's a
huge celebration,
and marching and dancing
and everything like that.
It ended up being this
really wonderful day.
So that's the second skill
that I want to talk about,
that ability to relate to
ourselves, to our suffering,
with openness, with compassion.
To relate to those
experiences primarily
as sensations in
the body that we can
bring openness and compassion.
And then the third skill
that I want to talk about--
I'm going to turn
these slides back on.
There's the one of
the General Assembly
meetings at Occupy Wall Street.
OK, so sometimes holding our
suffering feels like this.
Sometimes, our fear, our grief,
our anger, we can recognize it
and we can kind of hold it,
and that's kind of the image.
It when you're thinking
about mindfulness,
this is the image that I'd like
for you to have in your mind.
However, sometimes we try to
come home to our suffering,
and it looks a little
more like this.
And so there's this
question of how
do I find compassion for that?
How can I find it in myself
to have love and compassion
for this part of me?
And it's particularly
problematic
when we're being
self-destructive,
when we experience ourselves
as being self-destructive.
Those are the parts of us
that are often the hardest
to relate to with compassion.
So in my first book,
in "Self-Compassion
in Psychotherapy,"
there's a client that I--
sort of a case study
that I write up,
that I'm going to share
a little bit about,
to talk about this problem.
His name, as the case
study, his name was Chris,
and he came to therapy.
He said that he
had been depressed
with intense self-criticism
for a long time,
and that I was the I think
the fifth therapist that he
had seen in two years.
No one had helped.
So I was already really excited.
And so I said, OK well, tell me
about what you want to work on.
And he said, so I've
got this intense amount
of self-criticism, and whatever
I do doesn't seem to help
and he talks about
whenever he had a success.
He felt like an imposter,
like he was just moments
away from being
kind of found out
and that just going through
life, whenever made a mistake,
he was incredibly
critical of himself.
And so we started
off, and I said,
well, maybe we can try
a couple of practices
and see if we can find
something that might help you.
Would you be willing
to try a practice?
We can try a few things
and see what might help,
and he said, well,
what do you want to do?
So I described him a mindfulness
of the body practice,
and he's like, nah, I've
read all about mindfulness.
It doesn't help me.
I said, OK.
So then I described a another
self-compassion practice
about like the voices
or thoughts in his head.
And he's like, no, that sounds
really similar to something
another therapist did.
I don't want to do that either.
We spent pretty much a full
hour-long session going through
just about any
orientation that I
could think of for working on
depression and self-criticism.
And every single one
he had either tried,
and it didn't work, or it just
couldn't possibly work for him.
And so the term that kept
popping up in my mind
was a term by the
Harvard psychologist
Robert Kegan called
competing commitment.
And what Kegan means by
a competing commitment
is that it's
possible for someone
to genuinely want to
stop being depressed.
And yet for another
part of them to be
afraid of letting go
of their depression,
or whatever that symptom
is, competing commitments.
And that's kind of what
was coming up in me.
It seems like
everything I'm doing,
Chris was finding some way to
kind of not go along with it.
I was kind of
getting that sense,
so we end up trying a
practice looking into that.
But I want to talk a little
bit about competing commitments
first, because it's I feel like
one of the most important areas
for really understanding
self-compassion.
Because what it
means ultimately is
relating to every
part of myself,
even the self-destructive
ones, with understanding
and compassion.
Now usually, when we
think about somebody
who's like really self-critical
or self-sabotaging or just
incapable of taking
a complement,
it seems like they're just
being self-destructive,
or that there's something
sort of dysfunction
about their way of relating.
But I want to talk
about that and question
that a little bit in
terms of finding a way
to develop compassion for
those parts of ourselves.
So to go back to our
slides for a second,
when you see a moth
fly into a flame--
that moth's about
to kill himself.
Why do they do that?
Well, when we look at
a moth just like a bee
line for a flame and
die, we generally
don't assume that moth
just hated himself.
Right?
We come up with some other
story for why the moth did that.
In general, we might
believe that maybe they
use light to
navigate, and they get
confused by artificial lights.
That's a really common
idea that people
will talk about
why that happens,
even though it's
factually untrue.
Entomologists say that moths
don't use light to navigate.
We don't actually
know why they do this,
but we tend to come up with
some sort of explanation
that there is a life-serving
purpose that gets confused.
Whenever we see an
animal acting in ways
that might be considered
self-destructive,
that there must be some
sort of life-serving purpose
that's just out of
context a little bit.
And we do that because
evolution doesn't really
make sense unless you assume
that life is motivated
by avoiding suffering
and trying to meet needs,
trying to thrive.
Otherwise, when you're
talking about evolution,
it's hard to say
what's driving--
how to explain any
of these behaviors
in terms of evolution.
But we don't necessarily do
that with our own behaviors.
We don't give
ourselves the benefit
of the doubt in the same way
that we might with a moth.
Now, trying to understand
what gets confused--
if we want to assume that
whatever self-destructive
behavior--
we might engage in
self-sabotaging behavior--
that Chris, his depth
of self-criticism
and his whatever ways that
he's kind of avoiding therapy.
If we're trying to assume
that that is motivated
by some sort of life-serving
purpose that gets confused,
we need to understand
a little bit
about why it could be confused.
And actually,
there is a new kind
of subfield of
neuroscience that's
teaching us a lot about this.
computational neuroscience.
For a long time,
neuroscientists,
from the beginning
of neuroscience,
they were only really able
to learn about the brain
through injuries.
Right?
Somebody gets-- an
animal or a person--
an animal gets a lesion or a
person gets a brain injury,
and we see how it affects them.
And for a long time, up until
more recent brain imaging,
that's the only way we're
able to really learn
about how the brain works.
Starting with when we
invented functional imaging,
we were then able to learn
a lot more about the brain,
being able to kind of look
at it in live subjects.
But still, it's
like if I could just
take a scan of what
my computer is doing,
like as the electricity
is moving around,
you can't really learn
that much about how
my computer works just by
kind of looking at a scan.
The fields of artificial
intelligence and machine
learning have
gotten to the point
now that they're making
novel contributions
to the field of neuroscience.
And one of the main ways
that they're able to do that
is by taking theories that are
put forward by neuroscientists
and biologists,
biologically-grounded theories,
and they're able to
formalize those theories
and test them computationally.
Like, does this
actually behave--
in what ways does
it, and in what ways
does it not behave
like an actual brain?
Probably one of the
most dominant ideas
in computational
neuroscience right now
is that the brain's core
functioning is to build models,
to build models of the world.
To take the chaos of our sensory
data, and to look for patterns,
and to use those
patterns to construct
models of how the world works.
But what that means is
that all of our actions
are being mediated
through these models
that we have of how to avoid
suffering and find happiness.
And all of our models
are constructed out
of our past experience.
And so kind of recognizing
that a worldview that
sees human beings want to avoid
suffering and find happiness,
but we just generally
don't know how.
Because we are filtering those
impulses through imperfect
modeling of the world.
And that in some ways,
recognizing that a human being
is someone who--
it's actually very similar
to the idea in Buddhist
psychology, that
ultimately what we
want is to avoid suffering
and find happiness,
but we don't know how.
Coming back to Chris,
so what we did,
he came back the next session.
I said, you know,
I'd like to try to--
can we go through some
sort of practice today?
He said, OK, I'll try something.
And what I did was I asked him
to picture himself in a moment
that he was feeling
really depressed.
He talked about
earlier that week he
had stayed home and overeaten,
played a lot of video games.
And his girlfriend asked him
to come out to a dinner party,
and he was isolating.
He turned her down,
and he was just
overeating and
playing video games
and feeling terrible
about himself.
And I asked him to picture
himself back there,
and just sit with
that for a moment,
let himself get in touch
with, bring up those feelings.
And from the perspective
of recognizing
that whatever part of him
is active right now is--
it has a life-serving purpose
that we don't yet understand.
I asked him to
finish the sentence
"I refuse to let go of my
depression, because if I did--"
and he immediately said,
"they get away with it."
I said, who gets
away with it, and he
goes, my fucking parents.
And we talked a little
bit more, and he
explained that he'd grown
up in a household where
it was a household where his
parents would be screaming
at him and demeaning him.
And then the phone would ring,
and they'd be like, oh hi!
Oh yeah, everything's
wonderful here.
How are you?
And for Chris, that
facade of needing
to put forth
everything is fine here
was actually more painful
than the emotional abuse
that he experienced
from his parents.
And that there was
a part of him that
felt like the only
way for me to have
any hope of my parents
admitting the reality of what
our relationship has been
is just to stay depressed,
to keep undermining my life.
Because as soon
as I start really
succeeding, as soon as I
really let go of this stuff,
they're just going to
take credit for all of it,
and that was intolerable.
And as soon as I could recognize
how this undermining himself
was an attempt--
had a life serving purpose,
then we could integrate it,
and we could find compassion
for that part of himself
that just is terrified of
letting his parents win.
And eventually, he was able to
kind of consciously give up.
Give up hope on the
possibility that they
were going to respond to him
the way that he wanted them to,
and in doing that, he
no longer felt compelled
to undermine himself anymore.
Coming back to the workbook--
let's see.
There you go, yep.
Coming back to the workbook, the
Self-Compassion Skills workbook
is organized as kind of a flow
chart of different practices.
In my first book,
"Self-Compassion
in Psychotherapy," Richie
Davidson wrote the foreword,
and he describes research that
shows about 30 minutes a day,
for two weeks, of compassion
training is enough to create
measurable changes in both
brain physiology and behavior.
And so this workbook is
set up with that assumption
in mind, that taking 30
minutes a day, for two weeks,
to train yourself
in the component
skills of self-compassion.
But recognizing that
we're different,
and we have different
strengths, and we
have different obstacles.
There's a flow chart
that, depending
on what's coming up
for you, it points you
to whatever practice is going
to be most appropriate for you
in that moment.
So you start every training
session at the beginning,
and move from one
practice to the next,
depending on what
comes up for you.
So we're at a good
place, I think,
to open up for questions,
thoughts, and comments.
So I think Van has a mic there.
MICHAEL VAN RIPER: Yeah,
I'm going to-- maybe Brandy,
you'll be my mic runner?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is [? Sarup. ?]
I'm part of gPause team.
I teach meditations and yoga.
I [INAUDIBLE] look like I'm
a taking a personal session
and asking you a question,
but it's kind of like,
so I teach meditation, right?
TIM DESMOND: Sure.
AUDIENCE: I'm learning
mediation from the day.
I'm going to school,
because my schools are
teaching meditation.
But now, still even after
practicing meditation
from so long, right, still
there is a little anger in me.
TIM DESMOND: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Right?
There's still little because
people point this out.
You are practicing this long.
TIM DESMOND: Sure, sure.
AUDIENCE: Why the hell
do you have anger?
But now the problem--
now, you know?
Even discussion is
coming to me, myself.
Right?
The point is right.
I'm practicing meditation
for so long, why
there's still this anger.
Now, I want to share
the situation as well.
TIM DESMOND: Sure.
AUDIENCE: That is
causing the anger.
So I belong to a
very poor family.
Somehow I managed to
reach Google today,
and I want to give back
to the society, right?
So I was helping an
orphanage to fund.
Not just me, I collected
a bunch of friends
who were like me, somehow
least successful in their life,
and we were supporting
an orphanage.
But since we are
busy with our life,
and we were not ready
to really go and check
what the hell is happening,
we just give money to support.
But one day I realized that the
orphanage we all were funding,
they were giving
drugs to the kids,
and they were abducting
kids from other places
to just make the orphanage big.
Right?
So all of a sudden,
this give me an anger.
I know I myself [INAUDIBLE]
I teach meditation.
TIM DESMOND: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And I do know well,
should just enjoy the fact
that, OK, stuff happen.
Now, look in the future,
and don't do the mistake.
Or I just keep this
small anger in myself
to help me motivate
to fight against it.
TIM DESMOND: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So my question is,
should I let go and enjoy
my life, or should I keep this
anger and fight against it?
TIM DESMOND: Yeah, yeah.
Thank you.
I'm glad you feel
angry about that.
Some people talk about
the goal of meditation
is like to no longer
have negative emotions
or even to stop your thinking,
as though like being brain
dead is like a better
situation than being alive.
So for me, any
type of meditation,
the goal of that
meditation comes
down to what is your
goal about the person
that you want to
be in the world.
And actually, it's not
so much like how can I
be a good meditator and
just embody whatever
goals are part of that.
You find a lot more
success in discovering
who do I want to be?
What's important to me?
What are the qualities that
I want to develop in myself,
and then I want to train
myself in those qualities,
and I want to know why.
Why do I want to be this
way and not that way?
Right?
So like in what way do I
want-- how would I like
to react in a moment like that?
And I'm 100% not
going to prescribe
some sort of a
right way to react,
but I can say that it is the
inevitable human response when
you're in touch with
suffering that it brings up
suffering in you.
In Buddhist
psychology, the saying
is that the nature of mind
is dual and permeable.
If you're really
happy, being around
you is going to make me happy,
and if you're really suffering,
being around you is going
to bring up suffering in me.
The question is, what do I
do with the suffering that
comes up in me?
Am I dominated by it?
Suffering, I would
say, is a good servant
and a terrible master,
because suffering
is a necessary
component of compassion.
There would be no compassion,
if we couldn't suffer.
So I recognize the
suffering in me,
and then I want to relate
to that suffering with love
in myself.
I want to be able to
accept that in me,
and I want to be
able to recognize
that the entire spectrum
of human experience
is welcome in me.
I want to make
friends with my anger.
I don't want to somehow decide
that I shouldn't be angry.
And that the more that I'm able
to make friends with my anger,
the more that I'm able to listen
to it and act with wisdom.
Thank you.
MICHAEL VAN RIPER: So we're
actually almost at time.
Well, we can take
another question.
I just want to be
respectful if people
have to go somewhere at one.
I also don't know if our live
stream will cut out that one,
or if we can keep it
going for a little bit.
But I had one question
from the Dory,
and then we can go for
a few minutes past,
because we have the
room beyond one.
This person had two questions.
We'll see [INAUDIBLE].
What can we do every day to
stop being negative and bringing
ourselves down?
That's the first
question, and also,
after I speak with someone, or
I'm afraid to approach someone,
I get very angry and have
regrets for not being confident
and beat myself up.
How can I deal with
those feelings?
We have limited time, so you can
choose which of those two you--
TIM DESMOND: I'll
use the second one.
It's a little more [INAUDIBLE].
It's more like specific.
I want to approach somebody
and insecurity arises in me.
So the real question
is, how can I be
kind to the insecurity in me?
How can I recognize--
instead of identifying
with it, instead of
saying like, this insecurity
is me, and it's bad,
I can recognize that
insecurity is something
that every human
being experiences.
And probably, it's
a transmission
that I've received from
whatever experiences
or my parents, my ancestors.
And the question is, how can
I relate to that insecurity
with compassion?
So after I want to
approach somebody
and then don't and
feel bad about it,
then I want to
stop and recognize
that there is insecurity in me.
And I want to ask
myself, is it possible
for me to relate to this
insecurity with compassion?
Now, the insecurity
in me, if it seems
like a beautiful crying baby
that just feels anxious,
then I can hold it like that.
If it seems like
a little monster,
then I need to look
a little deeper
and try to understand
how is that insecurity
have some sort of a
life-serving purpose?
How is it trying
to keep me safe?
How is it trying to steer
me away from suffering
and toward happiness?
And if I can see
that as the basis,
then it becomes easier to
relate to with compassion.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you.
Really don't have a
whole lot of words
to describe how I feel right
now, other than this feeling
of coming home.
Just everything that
you've talked about,
there's just this
resonance of home.
So thank you for that.
TIM DESMOND: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
my question though
is when you were talking
about the first tool,
about seeing what's
already beautiful,
So I do a lot of that.
And it's something
that I do daily,
and it's come naturally to me.
But something-- I am a fixer,
and I love to solution things,
and I have this
commitment to my life
that if I'm going to
complain about something,
I better have a solution.
TIM DESMOND: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Or else,
don't complain about it.
And I have an 11-year-old
boy, and there's
a lot of litter in San Jose.
It's absolutely filthy, and my
eye is constantly seeing it.
And it comes-- my
mind says, well, this
is because I want a solution it,
and that's a beautiful thing.
TIM DESMOND: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Well,
a couple of weeks
ago, my son said to me, mom,
stop looking at the trash
and look at everything
else that's beautiful.
It's not the only
thing that's around.
And I loved that
he said that to me.
He's a beautiful mirror.
And I said, yes,
you're right, but if I
don't look at the trash,
then who's going to fix it?
TIM DESMOND: Yeah,
so it's a balance.
Right?
AUDIENCE: Right.
TIM DESMOND: It's not
only look at the trash
or pretend the
trash isn't there.
Right?
We want to be like--
the question is like, who
I want to be in the world?
I want to be somebody who acts
to make my community better,
but who isn't debilitated
by the amount of work that's
in front of me.
Right?
So what I want to do is it's--
and that's when we talk
about being present,
what it means in this
situation is coming back to you
in this moment.
Do I need to be looking
more at the litter,
or more at everything else?
It's not about always.
It's right now, do I move myself
a little left or a little right
in order to be in the place
that I want to be right now?
And so it's this
constant question
of re-orienting and
finding a balance that's
going to help me be the
person I want to be.
AUDIENCE: That's was perfect.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
It's great talk.
I did enjoyed it.
I wanted to ask about one thing.
So definitely the 30 minute
training every day something
that might--
I can definitely see
it having benefits.
But most of us in our
work, we are engineers.
We are writing code or dealing
with maybe all kind of stuff
at work or at home.
I also saw this kind of probably
there's an answer already
to it, but I would like to
see some sort of tools that
can help me in the moment
rather than doing a training 30
minutes in the morning.
Would that-- I think,
I did see a third thing
which was the deck.
I don't know.
Maybe that's the answer to the
question or maybe something
else.
TIM DESMOND: You know,
what I would say is,
for me, what it comes
down to ultimately is
getting clear about who do
I want to be in the world?
What are the qualities that
I want to develop in me?
And so let's say what
I want to develop
is just sort of greater
peace, contentment, happiness,
whatever it is, compassion.
And there are four
basic categories
of personal practice.
A formal daily practice
is just one of them.
So first category we can think
of as a formal daily practice,
and the reason that
I orient the workbook
around the formal daily practice
is that most of the research
comes from explicit practice
for an explicit amount of time.
The second category, sort of
a broad category of practice,
we might consider an informal
moment-to-moment practice,
which is about recognizing.
So it might be finding one
activity that I do every day,
stepping into the
shower, turning
on my car, whatever it is.
And asking myself, can I
create a poem or a reminder
that will help me to get
into the frame of mind
that I would like to
be in, in this moment?
When my teacher,
Thich Nhat Hanh,
first became a Buddhist monk
in Vietnam, the first element
of his training he was
given a book of poems,
and he was told to memorize.
And there was a poem for waking
up, for putting on your robes,
putting on your shoes,
for washing your face.
And he was supposed
to recite these poems
as he went through
his day, and that
was like the first stage
of monastic training.
The poem-- he's translated
these poems in a book
called "Present Moment,
Wonderful Moment."
Kind of an example,
the poem for waking up
is, waking up this
morning I smile.
24 brand new hours to be alive.
I vow to look at living beings
with the eyes of compassion.
So you say that.
So there is
moment-to-moment practice.
Then, there is
intensive retreats.
If you want to learn, let's
say, I like a foreign language,
what do they say is the
best way to do that?
Immersion, right?
So we can think of a retreat
as kind of like immersion
in the training of
mindfulness and compassion.
Similar to immersion
in language,
you take up a lot
more a lot quicker
with that sort of a practice.
And the fourth category
is a supportive community,
having people around you
that share your enthusiasm,
or that can at least
feed that purpose in you.
And so some people
really feel like
their daily formal practice
is where they shine.
It's what feels most important.
Other people aren't able to
do the daily formal practice,
but they try to go on an
intensive retreat once or twice
a year.
Other people, it's really
the informal practice
that they put their energy into.
So finding something,
trying out something
from those different categories,
can be really helpful.
But just like learning
a new language,
just like learning to play an
instrument, what it comes down
to is deliberate
practice in whatever form
that's going to take if you
want something to create
real change in your life.
MICHAEL VAN RIPER: We're
going to have to wrap it up,
but I want to thank Tim.
Let's give--
[APPLAUSE]